Here's why I prefer the African net sponge to a regular loofah.
So they're kind of the.
I mean, they're similar in design,
but look, my boyfriend took a shower with this a long time ago,
and look how soaking wet it still is since it's all bunched up.
This thing takes forever to dry.
The African net sponge,
because it's a long net,
it dries out. I took a shower with this not long ago.
Already dry.
There's not, like, big bunchy spots where it stays wet and be cut.
Like it's a bunch of tiny little knots on this nylon.
And then it's also the nylon,
so it exfoliates perfectly.
So you bunch it up just like what a regular loofah.
Bunch it up and exfoliate.
Then when you wanna wash your back, boom,
ready to go. Do the whole shit,
no problem. And it's got the perfect exfoliation.
These things are amazing.
I just love that they fucking dry off.
It's not nasty.
It's not still wet from your last shower
when you go to take your next shower.
They're amazing.
They're linked right here if you want to get one.